You are an international actress.
You grew up in Tokyo.
No, actually I grew up in Hawaii,...
...but I was born in Tokyo.
I've been living there for about four years,...
...coming back and forth, going back and forth from the States and Japan...
...and this is my first film that's shot in the States.
Yeah, thank you.
Well, I'm hoping it's helping me to represent my country well...
...and to be able to represent the Asian community in the film industry here.
I could speak Japanese before I went over four years ago,...
...but now that I've really reestablished my language and the culture more,...
...I think I can better represent them and show what we are...
...and what our country's about.
Yeah.